everybody Sean McGuinness and Carolyn
Pettit here at the Sony Playstation
showcase in Santa Monica we just had a
chance to go hands-on with PlayStation 4
exclusive the order 1886 from the ready
at dawn yeah and it seems like if
there's one focus to this gameplay
reveal that they showed us today it's
their kind of effort to create this
seamless transition between cinematics
and gameplay right how do you what kind
of sense do you get from that so the
demo just seemed like it was constantly
being interrupted by cutscenes and it
never built up any kind of momentum one
thing I will say that's definitely
working in this game's favor is there's
a real parity between the visuals in a
cutscene individuals in the game
absolutely and if there's one thing that
I did come away from that demo feeling
it's that it is absolutely a world I'm
curious about I want to get to know that
world better I want to know more about
these characters and the situation
they're in where there's a rebellion or
an uprising in London and and they the
the members of the Order themselves are
seen by many as kind of tools of the
oppressors yeah so it seemed like there
could be some really interesting moral
ambiguity at play here like you're not
necessarily you know clear-cut on the
side of good in everyone's eyes so you
know in terms of story and world the
demo we saw left me intrigued but the
gameplay aspects I felt were really
lacking yeah I mean the game played
there wasn't enough there to really sell
me on anything but you're right like the
world visual design of this setting neo
Victorian London is what they're calling
it yeah definitely pulled me in for sure
I think they're doing some really
interesting things there and you know
Victorian London was a very grimy place
yeah it was a very kind of like CD time
and it was a period of transition in
English history a lot going on and there
are a lot of horses butting up against
one another
slowly and clearly the game is is really
well researched historically I think
that that those historical seeds being
sewn into this world that it also has
all these fictional elements could lead
to some really fascinating stuff so
there you go the order a really striking
game remains to be seen whether you know
the gameplay has enough to really hook
people into it but you know it's a game
that still has a ways off and there's a
lot more time for ready event ready at
dawn kind of refine those gameplay
system so fingers crossed it all comes
together stay tuned for more coverage
coming your way in 2014